الانقسام الداخلي حول التعامل مع
الحرب وخاصه فيما يتعلق
باهدافه القضاء على حماس واستعاده الرهائن
هو خلاف علني هل ترصد استراتيجيه واضحه
لدى نتنياهو
بالبدايه مساء الخير سلمى استراتيجيه
بنيامين نتنياهو الان هي فقط في اداره هذه
الفوضه بمعنى انه ينتفع من الحاله القائمه
التي لا يوجد فيها حتى هذه لحظه تكتل على
مستوى المعارضه الاسرائيليه بما يشكل ضغط
حقيقي على بنيامين نتنياهو ولذلك ويدرك
نقاط ضعف الاطراف جميعها داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي او داخل القوى السياسيه
الاسرائيليه ويحاول قدر الامكان يعني
البقاء في هذه المساحه التي تتيح له
البقاء اطول فتره ممكنه في الحكم لانه كل
الاطراف التي يعول عليها على انها يمكن ان
تؤدي الى يعني امكانيه تغيير جوهري في في
مجرى العمليه العسكريه حتى هذه اللحظه
تتلك يبدو انها منتفعه كما بنيمين نتنياهو
بمعنى انه بيني جانس وايزن كوت يعني
اللذان نظر اليهما في اكثر من مره على ان
انسحابهما من مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي يمكن
ان يؤدي الى تكتل الشارع الاسرائيلي بشكل
اكبر يدفع بنيمين نتنياهو الى التراجع حتى
هذه اللحظه الارقام والاستطلاعات التي
تجرى داخل دوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تشير
الى ان بيني جانس ينتفع ويستفيد من بقائه
في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وبنيامين
نتنياهو يدرك ان انسحاب بيني جانس في هذه
اللحظه وان كان مرشح في مراحل لاحقه ربما
ينسحب لكن انسحابه الان قد يدفع بنيمين
نتنياهو الى المحاج امام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بان جانس انسحب من الجبهه
بمعنى ان اسرائيل ما زالت مجيشه وما زال
الاعلام الاسرائيلي يجيش المجتمع
الاسرائيلي في هذا الجانب وخصوصا اننا
نشهد في كل فتره عمليه عسكريه ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين تساعد في اعاده يعني اعطاء
الحرب الاسرائيليه مفعولها في تذويب
التباينات الاسرائيليه وعلى الاقل بشكل مض
كما حصل مع مقتل يعني اكثر من 20 جندي
اسرائيلي اذ شهدنا نوع من الوحده في
الخطاب الاسرائيلي وان كانت هذه الوحده
يعني برايي ستمضي يعني خلال يعني ايام
قليله و يعني ضمن عمليه التخبط كما ذكر
لابيد التي يعاني منها ايزنكوت وجانتس في
مساله البقاء في مجلس الحرب من
عدمه كيف تبدو الخيارات الزمنيه لهؤلاء
الاعضاء في مجلس الحرب ب
قياس ايضا التوجهات لدى نتنياهو واهدافه
المعروفه يعني بالنسبه لاعضاء مجلس الحرب
حين نتحدث عن اولئك الذين باتوا يعلنوا
يعني اهدا اولويات جديده الان وبشكل واضح
وعلني مثل جانتس وايزن كوت هم بحاجه اكثر
الى الوصول الى قناعه بان الشارع
الاسرائيلي يمكن ان يلتف حول هذه
الاولويات ولذلك يعني يعني نشعر بان هناك
توجس لدى بيني جانس في هذه اللحظات وخصوصا
اذا ما تبعنا خطابه الاخير يبدو انه يريد
البقاء في مساحه امنه بمعنى يريد ان يلبي
طموحات الشارع المنتفض من اجل استعاده
المحتجزين وفي ذات الوقت لا يريد استثاره
مشاعر اولئك الذين يريدوا استمرار العمليه
العسكريه فهو يقول انه لا تناقض بين هذين
الهدفين لذلك لا نتوقع من بيني جانس ان
ينسحب من مجلس الحرب الا حين ينضج الشارع
الاسرائيلي بشكل اكبر ونضوج الشارع
الاسرائيلي لا اقصد به اتساع يعني اتساع
الشريحه المؤيده لاعاده ترتيب اولويات
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي من حيث العدد لانه
حتى هذه اللحظه استطلاعات الراي تشير الى
ان الاغلبيه في اسرائيل تؤيد الحرب
الاسرائيليه واستمرارها لكن ارى انه
مفعولي وتاثير هذا الشارع بمعنى قدرته على
ارباك مجرى الحياه اليوميه للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي كنت اتابع مراسلكم الياس كرام
وهو يتحدث عن كيفيه انتقال المسيرات
الاسرائيليه ليس فقط من مجرد اعتصام يعبر
عن مشاعره تجاه المحتجزين وانما الانتقال
الى ض الى امكانيه اغلاق الشوارع
الاسرائيليه وربما في مراحل لاحقه نشهد
نوع من التصعيد من هذه الفئه بمعنى
الانتقال من مستوى التعبير عن الراي الى
الضغط وارباك الحياه اليوميه لاسرا الذي
لازال في في معظمه حسب استطلاع الراي كما
تقول وكما هو معروض ايضا
في الطرف الاسرائيلي هي لازالت تؤيد الحرب
ولكن الجمهور الاسرائيلي تصله اشارات
متناق قده
ومتباينه بين من قبل اعضاء الحرب يعني
مجلس الحرب الى اي درجه مثل هذا هذه
الاشارات وهذه القراءات المختلفه
والمتباينه في ظل اجواء الفوضى الموجوده
في مجلس الحرب قد تنعكس على الجمهور
الاسرائيلي في عمليه قراءته لاهميه الذهاب
والمواصله اكثر فاكثر في
خوضها هي بدات تنعكس يعني اخر استطلاع
للراي اجراه المركز الديمقراطي ايه
الاسرائيلي يشير الى ان ثقه الجمهوري
الاسرائيلي بمجلس الحرب تتراجع وان كان
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه ث يعني يحظى بثقه ما
لكن ثقتهم بالمؤسسه العسكريه اكبر ومن
يتابع الاخبار بتفاصيلها في اخر اسبوعين
نشهد انه المؤسسه العسكريه بدات ايضا
تتلاعب في الجمهور الاسرائيلي او بدات
تؤثر في الجمهور الاسرائيلي من خلال تسريب
الكثير من الاخبار حول الخسائر داخل صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي بمعنى ساعدت في تاجيل
الشارع الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى ذلك انها
بدات ترمي الكره في الملعب السياسي يعني
التصريح رئيس الاركان الذي يعاد في اكثر
من مره بالتلويح او التهديد او التحذير من
امكانيه تاكل الانجازات التي حققها الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا ليس من باب الامانه والحرص
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي على ضروره ان
يكون هناك تدارك للموقف وانما هو يريد ان
يقول للمجتمع الاسرائيلي ان ما كل ما قدم
من تضحيات من قبل جنود الاسرائيليين يتاكل
الان امام المصالح الضيقه لل المستوى
السياسي الاسرائيلي وتحديدا لبنيامين
نتنياهو وربما حتى في بعض الاحيان لي
جالانت وهذا الامر هو الذي يدفع الشارع
الاسرائيلي رويدا رويدا الى تصعيد مطالبه
من مطالب مرتبطه باعاده المحتجزين الى
اسقاط القياده السياسيه هذا ما تم خلال
الايام الماضيه وبالمناسبه استراتيجيه
بنيامين نتنياهو في التعامل مع هذا
الموضوع استراتيجيه نفسيه اكثر من كونها
استراتيجيه
ويقدم على ما يسمى التنافر المعرفي بمعنى
انه في ظل ادراكه لهذه الحقائق الموجوده
الان يحاول ان يقدم مدركات جديده محاله
الى المستقبل لا يمكن قياسها الان بالقول
مثلا هو تبع مسالتين المساله الاولى ان
الانتصار يمكن ان يتحقق في افق سته اشهر
وبالتالي هذه مساله مؤجله لا يمكن المجادل
الان لماذا لم يتم تحقيقها لانه يعطي اطار
زمني فضفاض والمساله الثانيه انه لما اشتد
الخطب وبدات الناس تتظاهر امام مقر اقامه
بنيامين نتنياهو قدم مدرك جديد متعلق
بمبادره يعلم جيدا ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
رفضها لانها تقزم مساله المفاوضات من
مفاوضات مرتبطه بالمسالك برمتها بالازمه
برمتها بما فيها قطاع غزه والحصار
والمستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه و المشروع
السياسي الفلسطيني ككل ويضيق الى مساله
تبادل اسرى وهذه ليست المعضله بمعنى ان
الاشكاليه ليست في تبادل محتجزين مقابل
اسرى فلسطين
وانما المعضله التي تقدمها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه الان ان هناك ازمه حقيقيه
يعيشها الفلسطينيين في مرحله ما قبل
السابع من اكتوبر ولم تكن هذه العمليه
لتتم في السابع من اكتوبر الا من اجل فكفك
كل هذه المعضلات التي يعيشها المجتمع
الفلسطيني ولا اظن ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ستقدم على القبول بمثل هذه المبادره